(laughing)
- [Man] Liquid Ass is a stinky liquid
that smells like butt crack
with hints of dead animal.
- [Narrator] So, there are these guys.
- Andrew Masters, I make Liquid Ass.
- Allen Wittman, Liquid Ass
creator and head janitor.
- We make the world's best stink product.
- [Narrator] And they work here.
- [Allen] This is what
we call the Ass Factory.
- [Narrator] They hated their jobs,
so they followed their dreams and started
a successful prank product company,
specializing in a really
rancid fart spray.
But they needed a name.
- I said, "So, what we gonna name it?"
And he's getting ready
to sit down and he goes,
"I don't know, Liquid Ass?"
And I'm like, "That's it."
(funny music)
- [Narrator] Then
something curious happens.
- [Allen] We're making
a product specifically
for pranks at first, but
then we start getting calls
from military people.
- [Narrator] Enter Stu Segall, this guy.
- Stu ordered from us,
and I'd never met Stu.
It sounds like he's got a,
you know, a pretty neat business.
- [Narrator] He really does.
- And he’d come up with the
idea to use it for a triage,
but the fact is that it
goes from prank product
to medical field is sort of a,
sort of a jump.
- [Narrator] Turns out
there's a secondary market
for this stuff, training
some of the most elite
armed forces to do their jobs.
- We are a company that
replicates the environment
of combat and right now we are in a set
that we built for medical training.
- Woah.
- Oof.
- Woah!
- [Narrator] Basically,
before this prank fart spray,
some of our best troops
and emergency medics
were going into the field
completely unfamiliar
with the overwhelmingly
horrid smells of death
and disembowelment that they
would probably encounter
as part of their jobs.
- It's a very awful smell.
It's something that
could actually gag a maggot
as far as I'm concerned.
It just smells like Liquid Ass.
- [Narrator] Back to these two jokers.
- [Allen] Now we have a product out there
that's helping military
training, which is great.
- [Narrator] You know,
not all heroes wear capes.